i know a lot of guys are like
when when they get into a relationship
or they get into a marriage
it's like once they start pooling their
money together then
you're exactly right aaron it's like
that's when women go oh
well what's what's mine is mine and
what's his is mine and so the the
collective of the you know that big pot
of cash that they all put
put put into that's one believe that
they are
not only are they the authority in the
relationship and in the marriage
they are the authority of the financial
decisions and this bears out in
in statistics as well like i've talked
about this in that infographic that i
bring up every once in a while
how over the course of of a marriage of
the
of modern like western marriages 90 of
financial decisions that are made by
that family are made by the wife
she's the one that's like decides this
is the kind of car we're gonna get
this is the true this is the vacation
we're gonna take this is what we're
gonna this is the house we're gonna buy
this is where we're gonna be that kind
of stuff
all of those sort of life decisions that
revolve around money
90 of those are made by women and
um when it comes to the joint uh part
like
what what money do you guys share um the
that's the lines i mean what we need to
like if we're going to if we're going to
save up for a house we're going to do
um you know if we're going to make it
like i make investments
um because i'm the investment guy like
my wife doesn't know anything about the
stock market she doesn't know anything
about crypto she doesn't know anything
about that so i'm
the one that makes those decisions and
that money comes out of
our money and sometimes my money too
like if i want to put like like if john
says hey get into
ethereum i might go okay here well i'll
throw my money out real quick just as
a test kind of thing but um so when it
comes to investments when it comes to
retirement that's that's on me
but as far as like paying the mortgage
paying the rent that kind of stuff it's
like
i leave that to her primarily because
she's a list maker and she's a worrier
so she wants to know where that stuff is
going and how it's how it's going out
and as a result i have to sort of be
involved in that as well so it's like
there's there's the the financial and
economic
type things that i take care of we both
take care of together
then there's the things that i only take
care of in it so it's kind of like
a partnership but i'm also sort of like
my own entity
from within that got it so so it's like
you have three corporations you have the
business of mr tamasi mrs tomasi
and then the marriage itself now when it
comes to
um contributions to the shared pool
um for things like investments
retirement housing you know stuff like
that
do you contribute 50 50 do you
contribute as a percentage of
your income we have separate we have
separate um
separate uh we don't have a a joint 401k
we don't have a joint retirement front
we don't have joint like
it's in my name for well someone most of
them are in my name
uh then there's her stuff too because of
her career and this stuff that she does
as well
and so it's not like we went and said
okay this is what we're gonna do it's
just that's how the cards
fell out that's just how we started
doing it and it seemed to work and so
that's
that's basically just what i went with
so um but i do know what you're saying
because i remember
um when i was i was moving um i was
moving funds from
one financial brokership over to another
and you're if you move over and and
maybe aaron knows something about this
this maybe this is a united states thing
i'm not really sure but if you move a
large amount of money from your
retirement fund into another like if you
go from like
uh you know t row price or something
into something else and you move like
200 000
or like half a million dollars over they
will they will say is your wife aware of
this does your wife know that you're
you're you're moving this money over and
it's like if they don't ask that or if
they don't get like a signed permission
slip from your wife you can they will
they won't do that and it's not
necessarily because it's a legal thing
it's they're covering their ass because
they don't want to be sued for it
for not having asked that so it's not
like there's something some law on the
books it's just their policy
because they probably in the past have
been sued by
guys who are moving their money away
from like one account in preparation to
divorce that woman
so that money is free and clear which is
kind of ridiculous because
a a savvy attorney is going to be able
to get get to that anyways
yeah they have a thing here called uh
fraudulent conveyance and they can turn
back the clock two years so if you
so if you did anything fraudulently to
like move money to hide it from
creditors from your
uh partner in a divorce or anything like
that um make sure you start that like
three years ahead of time i thought that
was interesting because it's like
there's this financial
like i didn't had never run across that
before and you know me being royal
tomosi is like i'm i'm going
really is that a law and they're like no
it's not a lot it's just our policy
and that i remember i was at the same
time lawyers made that policy up
i was exactly i was experiencing that
and then i had somebody else tell me
like they were going to get a
a vasectomy and the doctor wouldn't do
it unless his wife said
you you you got to have a permission
slip from your wife to get a vasectomy
because she has to know that yeah like
it makes sense if
yeah and you don't want like you know or
or to put like a line of credit against
your house like if you're in a
matrimonial home you know for example
you need the consent of the other person
to borrow against the house
but i mean like you think something like
a vasectomy you could just get that done
as an adult but in today's world
no it's not no you need the permission
of your partner
does she need your permission to get a
boob job though probably not
right
you